everybody, bonjour, hello, governor, bonjour, bonjour, oh
shit, wrong flag, right, I'm sorry, I'm all over the place,
it's outfit reveal day, and it's bronze medal match, it got
the clothes on, I, let me get the flags correctly, uh, all
right, let's see, where are my flags, or my collection of
flags, uh, there you go, there we go, now I gotta remember
to flip Is this already flipped?
I can't tell anymore, right?
No, I gotta refl- Wait, do I gotta flip this?
I- do I gotta- Okay, no, I don't.
It's already flipped correctly.
It's- All right, there's not a prediction of what it's gonna
be.
I just forgot to reset the score.
All right, so it's the battle, battle of the colonizers.
Battle for Canada's custody.
me.
Viva La France.
Love to give a super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, England's flag is, don't worry.
Let me flip it back.
All right, it should be good now.
Where's it?
Oh, Embappe is here.
Embappe.
Finally, the 100-year war sequel that I've been looking for.
Didn't expect it to be a bronze match, but I'll take what I
can get.
looks amazing so much creativity went to the skin so you
revealed it too quickly no it's thank you super chat thank
you thank you this is the outfit reveal that everybody was
looking forward to yes i know it's not wise to do an extra
watch along um before the outfit reveals because i could be
working on my outfit reveal right now um but hey i'm here i
should be working on prepping for the But hey, I'm here.
I also haven't eaten lunch yet.
Sorry, I can't help, but do we...
I just realized what the phrase was for what kind of gamer I
am.
I'm a gun and ball gamer.
Apparently, they're the worst type of breed of gamers.
Oops.
Hey, hey.
But has there been a V-tuber ball and gun gamer?
Don't worry.
I'm here to represent you guys, the underrepresented.
100% Finally, a Quebec outfit Duck, thank you for the super
chat Thank you, thank you I'm just Canadian This is a real
Canadian experience Oh no Doki is a Darby Thank you, Doki
Finally, my voice will be heard Yeah Yeah, la ho ho ho,
ain't it?
It's Tuesday.
What the fuck already out?
Oh, shit.
Wait, the game started.
I was like, damn, already out?
And then I forgot to start the timer.
Alright, give me a sec.
Oh, my God.
They got rid of the timer.
I don't fucking...
Where's the timer?
Why did the timer stop?
How am I supposed to time anything?
Oh, my God.
I already fucked it up.
Hit the timer for some fucking reason.
Okay, there we go.
We're okay.
Don't worry.
Yeah, our win rate will still, no matter what happens, it'll
be 100%.
You don't even care anymore.
Where's Jude?
Doki is a ball and chain gamer.
The ball and chain is my little rival.
Quail, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't realize there was a term for, like, people who like
FPS and also like ball.
Apparently they're, like, We were like, oh, no, they're the
worst type of game.
He's not start.
Wait, he's not?
Why?
What's the point?
I guess he's too mad.
It would have been such a good game.
Inbappe versus Jude Bellingham.
Oh, what does boyfriend think?
Oh, shit.
That already?
He's just chilling.
I liked how, oh yeah, I got a comment because I was like,
you know, uh how i decided to randomly play uh i know right
my my scott sports my ball and gun gamer playing games that
aren't ball and gun but anyway anyway i got comment on the
the f whatever the ea f soccer football game i don't even
know what the fuck the game's called and um oh What?
A red...
What?
I...
That's two minutes!
You know what?
Maybe Jude was the problem.
Maybe...
Two minutes.
Wait.
Show me imbappe.
I want to know how he feels.
I want to know how imbappe feels.
How does he feel?
What...
What does L-bappe feel like right now?
What the fuck?
I'm like, God, I'm like trying to tell a story.
Chill out.
I didn't even know what happened.
Yeah, first goal already.
Wait, I'm behind.
Wait, I'm so behind.
Give me a sec.
I just fast forwarded it.
I didn't I think I actually paused the game.
I'm so behind.
Let me fix the timer.
I fast forward guys No, whatever was like first goal.
Oh, yeah.
Give me a sec.
I'm so behind It's I was very very much so not because
someone was like joking that goal was like X amount of
seconds ago and I was like there's no way.
All right.
Now I'm on track.
I'm good now Yeah, I didn't even realize.
All right, anyway, what was I going to, what was I seeing?
I forgot my story.
I got distracted.
I got distracted by the fucking two-minute goal that we had.
I mean, that, there was like literally no defense.
Like what?
Oh yeah, I got a comment.
they're like hey I like Doki and I like football so I'm
gonna watch this and then and then and then they edited the
comment and was like I hate it when vtubers are chasing fads
and are larping and don't even know what the fuck they're
talking about and I was just like bro I played I played
football in that middle of the house I was like if anything
I think I know more about the game but because I played i
was in the i was in a varsity i just never played the what
was it the f23 the fifa sport game before i never played the
the fucking i never played 2k i never played like sport
games that yeah i was called a poser because they think i
just i didn't know ball i what okay okay that was another
goal what happened to bro okay if the games are at the ass
and like after halftime if like england is like three oh i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna turn the stream off we're we're
just calling it here i don't think france is like that cares
i think they actually they're just like they're just like
they're just here for the vibes completely filling ham was
actually don't you dare say that the war already ended it
was a 50-year war the sequel the sequel they have the the
100-year war.
I thought that was another goal, too.
That looked like another goal.
I don't even think, yeah, I don't think they want to play.
I think, like, because, like, bronze is just, you know,
nobody's really, nobody really cares about bronze.
I'm only, I didn't care until I realized it was England
versus France.
But also, I thought they would, um, I thought they would put
up a better fight.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
third place gets 30 million that's like that covers like
half their yellow cards and red card if you think about it
hey that covers like like almost half of the yellow cards
they got
all right good passes i get none i mean that's just reset oh
on my ankle anyway oh the french guy was like hey hey bro
come on and he's like come on man this is a third place game
bro come on even he was like bro this is third place
He's like, like, don't do this, man.
Come on.
And then England was like, oh, yeah, I'm fighting for third
place.
Let me get back up.
Oh, nice D.
Oh, is he still trying to fight for top goal score?
Is that his goal?
I mean, he's number one, right?
I mean, well, he just has to score more goals than, because
like, Yamel and Messi are both in the running.
right
he's tied with messy yeah but then they have he has to score
like what well the miku curse is 2-1 right so he has to
score at least like two goals oh yamels no oh he has assists
sorry i was thinking about i guess i got confused with his
assistant uh there's assist stats and his goal stats
everyone was saying yamel got hard carried oh i thought it
was really funny that uh yamel yamel messy bathed yamel um
and then like it's like it's like harry potter where like
like i was really funny oh that was a sick that was like
through the legs oh what a save yeah the bathtub picture
those who don't know um yamel as a child as a baby was the
boy who scored boy and the boy who scored but like basically
um Messi did an ad promotion or whatever an advertised photo
shoot or something and then coincidentally one of the babies
they picked for the ad where Messi had to bathe of the baby
was Yamel all those years ago all those years ago so people
were like it's crazy that it's now like Spain versus
Argentina will Yamel play against
oh oh oh he doesn't even care he doesn't he doesn't even
care it's just like all right this is such a sad game like
all sequels they won't they all They find a way to
disappoint me.
Like all sequels do.
Oh, was it offside?
Oh, that's why he didn't care.
Only one offside goal.
I'm lucky.
I was going to say he's just like, whatever.
Well, they had to give the money to someone.
They're just like, well, we have to, I, is there any British
VTubers even watching this?
Am I, I'm like, is there any British VTubers watching the
third place?
Am I the only one that cares?
Am I funny?
No, she's not even watching it, right?
I'm the only one that cares.
It's just, it's just.
It's just me.
I don't know.
Just me.
Okay, I was watching.
Yeah, the non-prints are watching.
Let's go.
Who gives a fuck?
As a Canadian, I'm here to represent both my colonizers.
I gotta support them.
Whoever wins gets custody of Canada.
I got larked till the end, exactly.
I thought it was funny where they're like, oh, they're just
chasing the fad.
I think the fad ended the moment Holland got eliminated
because I feel like no one in America cares anymore.
Because all the funny, you know, all the funny memes memes
like the um like the what stuff where like the americans
like love like the funny moments or like the countries that
they are we're all cheering for like after holland was like
the last man standing on the oh oh that was a good see yeah
no viking bald king how would i roll there's no more memes
guys wait in 2030 they're gonna have 64 teams wait is that
true is that actually true i don't know they are they adding
why why they're all gonna play nintendo 64 while they're
there
that's insane what's the point of qualifiers if it's 64
teams imagine not fucking qualifying Also, the games are
going to be really, really ass.
You're just here watching this.
Like, you're just going to watch the teams get absolutely
fucking destroyed.
Imagine being the 64th team that qualifies.
Guys, imagine you're the 64th team.
Yeah, everyone is here.
Yeah, it's like Super Smash Bros.
They're all here.
They might show up and play.
There would be a reason why they're the 64th.
team that qualifies maybe
with 64 teams Italy can come back
Cape Verde yeah but Cape Verde qualified that's that's a
qualified team
imagine imagine it's 64th team versus like Argentina like or
Spain I, they, they would, you know how there's a rule where
they score too many goals they legally have to stop the
game?
Like, he has no that rule, right?
We're, we're like, what was it?
What's the maximum amount of goals they can score before
they act to legally stop the game?
Like, yeah, the mercy rule.
How many goals?
Oh, no, there was one.
Wasn't there?
I remember they had to stop it.
it oh shit he's all the way there don't underestimate the
smaller teams i'm just saying if you're the 64th qualified
team i guess maybe like the first i don't well i bet you i
bet you if they are allowing 64 teams they will have to they
have to introduce it there i thought it existed in during
the olympics wasn't there a rule for it during the olympics
it's football there is no mercy
did he not offside not offside yeah i'm sorry these goals
are uh there is at least it's good head you know
I just remembered we're gonna have football again for the
Olympics I just remember that who did win um
who did win
look at Olympics from the last Olympic football game I don't
know who won last time
I don't even know if Mbappe exists in this.
I'm just like, I don't even know if he's existing in this
game.
I didn't get my cough drop.
I swear, we're like at 3.0 or 4.0, but guys, we're calling
it early.
We're time to diss up against sympathy, jerky.
I don't care anymore.
I'm not cheating.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think after what happened during the Argentina game, I
don't think the coach is going to park any buses anymore.
Wait.
Maybe Jude Bellingham was the prop.
Maybe.
I knew I remember watching China play football in a World
Cup environment.
It was because I was watching the Olympics for...
version.
Because I was like, I remember watching China, you guys were
like, China wasn't in the World Cup.
And I was like, yeah, they were.
They were in the Olympic World Cup.
Oh my God, here we go again.
Here we go again.
Can we get a third goal?
Okay, Mercy Raw football.
Is there a Mercy Raw?
They should introduce the Mercy Raw.
He might get jumped when he returns to England.
Guys, this is going to be the 50-year war.
Alright.
Oh my god, he's actually...
They're actually in the UK now.
Oh.
Oh, I'm Boppe.
Oh yeah, I watched...
He's just like...
Alright.
He's just like, okay.
Oh, I remember.
but that was what i was thinking of the germany versus
brazil when was that i was thinking about that game yeah
yeah and then people were like we need a mercy rule like all
right yeah that's that was the game i was thinking of yeah
yeah i think if there are 64 teams are qualified they have
to introduce it because what if you're the 64th team and you
get matched up with like any of the teams that are in the
semis like or even netherlands like if you got matched
against netherlands who've never lost a single game before
other than through penalty kicks like
like it would like at that point like i feel like if they
were against if you were in the 64th team to qualify the
team you're against if you're against any of the top four
teams they'll just put on all their subs because at that
point like what's like they they're gonna put in all the
substitute players they're gonna put the goalkeepers playing
in the like playing on attack field because they'll they
don't want to you know it's just kicking a baby at that
point it's just like they'll just put like they're like all
right all right goalkeepers All the goalkeepers substitute.
It's your time to shine.
It's your time to be a striker.
Quill, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I'm bopping the game.
How will they get?
Quill, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dude's not even in it.
Lamps is a slaughter.
Yeah, like, what's the point?
I feel like it's just...
You're just introducing more countries to...
I get it.
If there's 64 teams, that means 64 times more yellow cards,
which means more penalty money for FIFA.
That's where y'all, I figured it out.
More teams equals more yellow cards.
You know they're going to be kicking.
You know they're going to be tripping people.
Imagine all the yellow cards.
Imagine all the red cards and the yellow cards.
$1,000 per yellow card.
The infinite money glitch.
I cracked the code.
Hire me, FIFA.
I think I could make more money working for FIFA than
streaming.
Honestly, with the...
If it...
Not just including the bribes.
I'm just counting the bribes money.
Imagine all the bribes I can take.
Don't imagine how much money I'll have in my off-store bank
account.
I'm ordering food during this slurp game.
Like, one is not trying and the other one is existing.
And you can't tell which is which I'm talking about.
They're not even trying to kick each other anymore.
I'm going to order something small.
I want something small.
I might order, like, a small pokey or some shit.
Because I don't want to eat something too big.
Oh, yeah.
I saw Jimothy the raccoon.
I like how someone...
I like the tweet where they're like, uh before before uh
cameras and videos were a thing um he would be a cryptic and
he'll be like an urban legend or some and not every now but
now he's neat he's just jimothy the raccoon who doesn't know
jimothy the raccoon it's literally a raccoon that's born
without a neck and or like a long spine so he's like this
like bunched up he's like there's a bunch like he's like a
squished version of raccoon who also happens to have no tail
and then yeah he's really cute there's like dogs with that
condition because i've seen dogs that look like that before
well not in person oh my god oh my god what a fucking uh he
doesn't care the goalkeeper does not care
yeah I'll show you guys Instead of watching football I'll
show you a raccoon picture
I bookmarked it just Just for this special occasion I
bookmarked Jimithy So this is him as a baby And then Bro are
we We're watching the same game You know this is much more
priority than what the fuck We're watching right now Ha ha
ha ha If you are watching the same game, Jimothy is much
more important with what the fuck I'm watching.
So this is like, okay, but look at the first video.
The first viral video of Jimothy, though.
Oh, they kissed?
I missed it.
I was looking at Jimothy.
I'll re-I'll, let me rewind.
I can rewind this.
the day I actually kissed when did it happen at what time
I'm actually rewinding just to find it okay but the very
first video of Jimothy um like like if it was nighttime and
you saw that shit like I'd be like it's not an SCP What was
I lied to?
Was I fucking lied to?
I rewired it.
Oh, you mean I saw the kiss.
I saw, no, I know what you're talking about.
When, like, goalkeeper kissed the other guy, I mean, like,
good save.
Yeah, because it was like, it was a, because he was stupid.
Like, he was, like, he literally, the goalkeeper, like, I
bet you.
he would not do that in any of the like if it was a knockout
game um i mean if it was not bronze metal match he would not
have done that
oh okay he was trying to be really fancy with that one
where's imbappe pass it to him it doesn't matter if why did
you pass wait was that imbappe oh that's why i was like why
isn't he passing oh it was imbappe he does not care He's...
I was like, bro, pass that, bro, pass imbapit, and it was
imbapit.
I didn't realize it was him.
I was like, what are you doing?
You're not going to get that shot.
Pass it to imbapit.
Yes.
Plot twist.
He was imbapit.
If I'm imbapit, who do I pass to?
dude that's true every dribble is as if you think about it
him dribbling is considered passing the imbappe
france looks so over yeah like i this is such a i think this
i they should just get rid of the third place game just give
both teams third place at this point give them both third
and fourth and then like the like this is just a humiliation
ritual right there just let them go home bro let them
fucking party and where are they and where are they in
America right now yeah I'm watching tomorrow's game
like it's just sad
Miami yeah let them fucking go to the beach guys they just
want to go to the beach right now they this game could have
been an email you know I thought I'd be more excited because
it's England versus France but they
should with an all-stars game that would have been I think
that would boost sales so much and they've made an all-stars
game but then that would require like keeping the all-stars
like longer and I don't think FIFA wants that because that
requires them paying more money That requires them to spend
more money.
Because then, like...
Oh!
Okay, that's a good save.
That's a really good save.
Yeah, FIFA likes to keep their money.
That was a good save.
Ticket prices...
Yeah, but the thing is, they can't sell more tickets.
Because every...
game is technically a full house so it's like they're
already selling all the tickets but they can't sell more
tickets so i so so they're like what's the point i can't
make more money even by doing an all-star game people
already paying to watch third place
how do you get to decide who gets into the all-star games
literally all-stars if you recognize the You're a star.
Like, get the two best goalkeepers, the two best strikers.
Oh, my God.
Is Zimbabwe going to score?
Is Zimbabwe...
Oh!
What a save.
What is the goalkeeper the same one that wrote the
encyclopedia article about, like, the Spark Notes guide?
Is that the same goalkeeper for England?
Is that pitchfork?
no oh yeah even he's like check it out yeah I couldn't tell
I can't tell
yeah even pitchfork gave up whoa oh my god
I could be playing 10-inch attack right now but instead I'm
watching depression or something with super chat thank you
thank you Yeah, I'll just say that was give it to Mbappe.
That's all he wants.
I like how this his team does not care It's really pass to
Mbappe and Mbappe passes to himself and then shoots like His
other like his midfields and his like left and right ring do
not like he knows he's not gonna get a pass
I think it's so funny because you can tell he's just like
Like, well, and Papi has the boss, so it's not like I'm
going to do anything with it.
Like,
oh, it's a score still.
No, it's 2-0.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what is the goalkeeper doing?
Like, am I...
What the fuck?
What is the goalkeeper?
keeper and there's a what is he doing what is he out of his
who who is this goalkeeper who is he it's like a chicken
game of watching there's a king looney tunes game
i told you it'd be three or four zero by half time What a
fucking clown show.
It's like...
Like, what?
Get back in the fucking box!
What... Bro, let the defender do their job!
Like, why does he... He has defenders for a reason.
It's like Looney Tunes shit I'm fucking watching right now.
England when they don't park the boss
just feels like me playing playing the like f f e sports or
whatever and pop is just like at least it's coming home for
England yeah bronze he forgot what position he was playing
Bro, just call it.
Bro, they don't...
Like, Bellinab's going...
Like, Bellinab's just already heading back to the hotel.
Bro, he's just like, don't sub me, and I'm fucking going
home.
Like...
If they're...
Yeah.
She's like, I'm fucking...
I'm going to the beach, guys.
is there a mercy rule not in world cup
this is just embarrassing i was a french like oh my god you
know worst part tickets are so expensive they have to sit
here and watch i'm pretty sure when half time's over like
all of them are like the the french uh viewers are gonna
leave a lot of lift and king yay turnp Girl overlords.
Cucabera, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine being French right.
I know, but like, imagine being French right now and sitting
in that sand.
Like, yeah, paying 5K to watch France shit the vid.
You can't even rage quick because that's fucking 5K plus.
Imagine being a VIP for France right now.
was
he offside where his fucking pinky like let's see if he's
offside france is like please like it's fucking imagine a
pinky fucking got got caught by var
the one pixel bro like
they've never done it before they've never conceded three
balls in a half time before until now i'm mad it's it's
almost like they fucking don't care it's almost it's almost
they're they're like just just fucking end this like bro we
will we will make the mercy rule happen
no like even i had the goalkeeper's fucking at guys i'm
gonna call it at the half time like i i legitimately it's
just loony tunes game right now It's, it's
Imagine if that scored
By one by seven one scored Doki They can make more history
by forfeiting I gotta just spend the time prepping for the
outfit reveal
Like we're packing up Like if We need a 4-0, but 4-5.
They're dominating possession, but they're not even playing
their best players.
Like, that's the saddest part.
Like, this is literally, like, subs versus subs.
And England's subs are better than France's subs right now.
But the thing is, France put their star player, but England
hasn't even put their star player on the field.
Like, that's the worst, that's the saddest part.
Like, England does not care at all to the point where, like,
their star players aren't even on the field.
Their star goalkeeper's not on the field.
Their star striker isn't on the field.
Like, France is still playing after 11 subs versus M.
Buffett.
Wait, France has their starters?
That's so sad.
That's, that's, that's even worse.
I'm just going in assuming that this is not their, their A
team.
The fact that like England gave them their, their like,
their sub goalie after pitchfork's performance.
B team versus team of death.
This is literally England's B team.
And apparently half of France starters are playing.
Glad to be watching Retired Foujo.
It means I get expert analysis on some.
Jesus, thank you.
Let's see for chat.
Thank you.
It's a mix of both starters and B team.
At least the French have an excuse to go on strike and burn
down the Louvre.
Oh my god, it's Empape.
and BAPE wasn't there and BAPE wasn't there just fucking
twist a knife I swear we have no files nobody cares
that LBAPE wasn't a myth after all like I said M washed more
like
bro just try to shoot another goal get that they're just
playing with friends right now They don't even need to
solve!
They don't...
They...
England's just twisting the knife.
They don't even need to solve.
Like what is gonna...
What are they gonna do?
Like, really?
Like, oh, they want to do Harambaugh now.
Like, like, are you...
There's no reason to Harambaugh.
Like you think they're gonna...
Like, I'm not like, why?
They're just practicing how to pass.
They're trying to teach Mbappe how to pass, guys.
They're like, Mbappe, this is how you do it.
This is how you pass.
You see this?
You made...
Oh!
Handball.
It's
like...
What low morale does to a team?
Bro, you don't even...
Bro, just go for another score.
They're so demoralized, bro.
They're so fucking demoralized.
Just do it again.
I just do it again.
And he did.
He asked and he received.
They just did it again.
Bro, don't even put cameras on the French fans, you know,
this is not, it's just too sad.
And then you call it, what a day for the French president
even, this match is so unnecessary.
It's all over there.
English, score some fucking girls.
There should be a mercy.
How do I even tweet this?
This is the most Looney Tunes game.
Let them just let just call it and let let them go to the
beach.
I just fucking just call it we are about to witness cinema
right now
here we go here's another one
Let them just hang out at the beach, guys.
But Judah's not even there anymore.
He's gonna mercy roll this stream.
Carl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They're not even locked.
This is the B team.
This is England's B team.
What do you mean they're locking in?
This is like the most sad game I've ever seen.
This game is so sad.
Savvy's already dead.
Gia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They should have just fucking put in the C team at this
point.
Bro, I'm already...
Oh, my God.
Imagine if they like...
Germany being Brazil, 7-1 Brazil was the saddest.
Yeah, but we're about to see something even sadder today.
All right, guys.
I'm mercy ruling my own stream.
We need a forfeit button
I want to see a 12-0 Alright guys I'm calling it here This
is not even worth my attention anymore
Calendria, thank you for the Akasufa, thank you.
You know the match is worthless when Doki's team is losing
4-0 in the first half and she doesn't even bother changing.
It's just sad.
It's like, I'm just, I'm just watching the saddest game of
my life.
Like, I was looking forward to the 100-year, to the 100-year
war.
And instead, I don't even know what I got.
I'm watching a Looney Tunes episode.
I'm watching, like, the Emu Wars.
We're letting our hatred of France show here.
Seriously, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I thought France would fight back.
They just pulled up the white flag already.
Yeah, it's the Battle of Waterloo.
All right, guys.
I'm going to...
I was looking forward to the 100-year war.
sequel and then i got this and guys i'm calling it here the
game was too sad to watch and i will not be surprised if
england scores like seven more goals i just like they're
literally scoring what a goal every 10 minutes like i knew i
knew what game i was about to watch when we got a goal in
within two minutes i and then seeing the goalkeeper just
playing deep like becoming a defender and his defenders
becoming goalkeepers i knew exactly what game this was gonna
become anyways i'm gonna i'm gonna call it here guys i'll
see you guys for the outfit reveal i'm gonna prep the outfit
debut uh gonna prep for it um but i don't know what else to
say that was the most game I've ever watched out of this
entire World Cup experience.
So, yeah.
That's always everybody.
I hope we had fun though.
I hope we had fun watching the first half together.
At least we had fun experiencing it together.
Imagine being French right now at the stadium.
That would have been so much worse.
At least we're at home watching this.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check, get up,
and move around to get that blood flowing.
Except for me, stay a little longer, because it's almost EP
time with Doki Bird.
For my new outfit reveal, I would say it is one of my
favorite outfits so far.
So, I know I'm hyping it so much, but I was playing around
with my new skin suit yesterday, and I was having so much
fun, and I really, really, really like it.
so it is my favorite favorite new outfit so far so I hope
you guys like it too anyway I didn't have really much
prepared for it because I was planning a shadow dropping it
with nothing else it was like actually like not really a lot
of not really a lot of stuff going into it because the
outfit is the the outfit is the main is the main attraction
any guys i'll see you there uh bye everybody bye